hi everybody we're back here with tom
arnold and uh
we're in our uh mardi gras beads here
you uh used to work
you've talked in the past on the program
about the jobs you used to have yes uh
and and we didn't talk about this
because i wasn't aware of it used to
work at mcdonald's i worked at
mcdonald's in iowa city when i was going
to college and uh
on riverside there i also had the record
for the uh if you came in early on
saturday morning and unloaded the truck
not only did you get paid 250 an hour
but you also got to eat as much food as
you could you got one meal
and so my record is eight big macs a uh
a big giant malt a giant fry and an
apple pie and i would
always eat eight sandwiches because you
just gorge yourself as much as you can
how do you eat eight sandwiches it's not
that hard it's not that hard
you know you're a college student you
know it's gotta fill you up you don't
have any money
you just get you just it makes you sick
and you you don't feel good
you feel horrible but you just killed it
that's the trick to it yeah it was you
know it makes you sick
and we work there and i'll tell you
something it was nice because all the
food they threw away i took home to my
friends you know
and then the best thing one night they
had this contest there was a box every
big box case had 6 000 game tickets in
it you open it up you can win a million
dollars or you would a big mac or
whatever
we me and i told i stole the box i you
know i paid him since then i had i felt
bad i gave him donation ronald mcdonald
house we're all buddies now
anyway and you got to do that anyway
my buddy mike's four weeks at home
opened up all six thousand of them
pulled each thing open
you know we had at the end we didn't win
the million dollars but we had like a
200 big breakfasts
and 300 hot cakes and sausage so the
next morning we had this party
and then we went in the next morning so
everybody can eat breakfast so my buddy
mo goes in there
and he has all this stuff and then they
go you know you can only turn in one of
these at a time and he says
boy the kids at the home are gonna be
disappointed you know so
here's a guy with booze on his breath
and everything and they're like well
okay well they get accepted so here it
comes
they bring a band load full of the food
we had a great time and you just like
sat in it and ate your way well but
there was a bunch of us you know
well you know it was it was great there
were six of you admitted yeah we were
all big
you were uh you are also you've admitted
that you're a pie eating champ i am a
a piety champ i won fifty thousand
dollars for my charity uh
center for children in san diego yes
right i ate but it wasn't just to get to
anybody it was uh
hulk hogan a guy named uh tugboat
typhoon i believe was his name a guy who
weighs a five 450 pounds and then
another uh great big uh guy fat guy from
iowa friend of mine jc birds anyway so
i'm the smallest guy
i ate 16 pieces of pie right and i won
this
contest i'm very good at it i've lost
weight since the summer but i trained a
little bit over the weekend
i had an idea here which is i i you know
i'm a thin guy but i can eat a lot yeah
you're big
and i thought i'm a big guy i'm six four
i thought that you're not that big
thanks i mean your trip uh that's oh
that was your stomach
that's a bulletproof vest yeah yeah uh i
thought that we should have you and i
should challenge you in a pie eating
contest right now if you're up to it i
will okay now wait
wait now tom here
tom here is a champ so i thought since
you're a champ it should be you versus
me and andy and we count as one unit
what do you say
all right all right andy's pretty good
andy's damn you go up and down on the
weight so you gotta be pretty good
is it is it like a speed thing or the
style camera
uh it's kind of more of a speed thing
it's whoever can eat the most uh pies
and we're going to give ourselves uh two
minutes you can eat a lot too baby
what piece of advice guys yeah don't
stop eating because you know then you
realize how full let's get into it right
now let's just see how we do
come on andy let's go
you want there tom and andy you here and
we'll figure this out here and
uh we got all kinds of pies here we're
just going to see who can eat the most
in two minutes
and then here is the planet hollywood uh
hollywood moose bites uh
it's really a good one to eat because
you can eat it really fast it's very
good all right liz are we all ready to
start the count the clock
and whoever how do we just so if uh
let's see if you win
i'll plug your movie the rest of the
night i'll keep mentioning okay great
great
and if we win you have to go on ridley
all right okay
all right wait how's that i've been
there before my friend okay
okay wait let's get sent home are we
gonna eat right out this hard gig yeah
we can just do whatever you want man we
don't have time this is a you know
improvised late night show not a lot of
thought goes into this and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right
[Applause]
seven six five four
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you